what happened with the voice he just
burned out on it or do you know it's one
of those weird things like obviously
been asked that question a couple times
but I need to know never people I really
well yeah I want the real answer the
real the real answer is that I was ready
to not be doing it anymore I think for a
little bit and I get that
and I think that when it all kind of
naturally happened I was like okay you
know this is feels right for for better
or worse at the moment in which we
decided to walk away felt really good if
this is the right time for me to go it
was just you know for an eight and a
half years I was so busy had the band
had the voice it was I was beyond
fortunate to go through all of it
because I really did have it was like a
life altering experience beyond that
show like honesty it was good for the
band right it was good for maroons fine
okay for everybody everybody where
everyone won everybody wins right and
then it got to the point where you know
I got married I had I had two kids and I
wanted to spend time with them and they
were really little how's that going
we're happy married yeah yeah I was and
she's the best mom and I'm just so mad
about you know you fall in love if
you're lucky you get to follow up
someone more than once you know and I'm
just like you're very much in love
they're very much in love